the Supreme Court will welcome its
newest justice on Monday that's when
Neal Gorsuch will be sworn in as the
courts 113 justice the Senate confirmed
Gorsuch on a 50 for 245 vote on friday
but it took a bitter fight in the Senate
to make his confirmation possible
Republicans use their majority to change
Senate rules allowing the minority party
to block Supreme Court nominees those
rules have changed by invoking the
so-called nuclear option senators from
both parties say the chamber will never
be the same I say to my friends on the
other side of the aisle and I say to my
friends on this side of the aisle that's
not the way the Senate was designed to
work but where does the Senate go where
should we go well I hope that we'll have
the good sense to restore the 60-vote
margin when it comes to future Supreme
Court nominees Gorsuch replaces Antonin
Scalia who died more than a year ago and
like Scalia he's expected to be a fifth
conservative vote on the nine-member
court now let's turn to fill a bum
national correspondent for The
Washington Post for some perspective on
a pretty intense week in Washington for
they're all in the same thing that's
like so so what do you think the
long-term impact Phillip is of invoking
this nuclear option in the Senate well I
think that it is it is sort of a
long-term symptom of what's been going
on and washed and the Senate was
designed to be the more stable body
there's a reason that not every sin
tener can be voted out in every single
election and it was supposed to be the
place where consensus was built in
contrast to the house which was which
was meant to be sort of more emotional
but partisanship has been so strong in
Washington over the course of the past
decade or so that was sort of inevitable
that the Senate would get to a point
where the filibuster standard the
60-vote margin that would be needed to
overcome filibusters which become more
and more common would fall by the
wayside Democrats actually pulled the
nuclear option first several years ago
and so I think particularly now with the
Democratic base so riled up about
president Trump it's not terribly
surprising the president has not been
shy about stimulating that he has
designs on Justice Anthony Kennedy seat
so what's the democratic calculation
here they basically taking power out of
their own hands yeah I mean there's
there was a big debate over this over
whether or not the Democrats should
filibuster Gorsuch and therefore trigger
what they anticipated would happen which
was that the rules will be changed be in
order to replace a conservative or the
conservative as I just pointed out that
it but the problem is that the
Democratic base is very very active
right now we're seeing lots of
fundraising for example for you know
special elections which we wouldn't
normally see a lot of fundraising for
because people are very amped up about
what happened last November and about
how Trump the vision the Trump has for
the country Democrats are very very
upset and I think that if the Democrats
had simply gone along with the Gorsuch
nomination right now there would have
been a lot of outcry at the grassroots
level which they weren't prepared they
think this might benefit them in 2018
somehow well possibly but i also think
they just didn't want to stir that
hornet's nest there are reports Philip a
number of reports that there may be a
shake-up in the White House that there's
essentially a power struggle inside
outside the Oval Office what do we know
about what's going on right now so
there's as always are a lot of rumors
coming out of the White House and and as
it's usually been the case those rumors
have had some element of truth to them
and so what we've heard the New York
Times reporting for example that right
now Trump is trying to isolate either
Steve Bannon or jared kushner as sort of
the primary voice within the White House
and telling them to sort of work through
the struggles they have they represent
very different aspects of trumps
initiatives and Trump's policymaking and
he sort of asked them to try and figure
out how they can work better together I
think this week was a was a blow to
Steve bandhan some extent he was taken
off the National Security Council he his
power seems to have been diminished
Jared Kushner has been given a lot he's
had a lot placed on his plate and so I
think that there was always going to be
tension between those two and I think
we're sort of seeing come to a head
we're going to be talking more about the
importance of White House Chiefs of
Staff Ryan's Priebus president Trump's
chief of staff is caught up in this
palace intrigue where do you think his
stock is at this point well I don't
think it stopped was ever terribly high
I mean people may remember that that
Trump was sort of trying to decide
between bannon or Priebus at the outset
for chief of staff and he sort of gave
them both jobs which I think was
necessarily going to lead to some
tension between them I think
pre-business sort of seen as having
shepherded the failed health care policy
plan which I think he's already
diminished stock i think really took a
at that point and you know what we're
hearing right now again the New York
Times report was Krishna vs. Bannon
Priebus not mentioned in that
conversation yeah thing and president
Trump supposedly saying work it out
between the two of you exactly right
what does it mean for help they're
taking another stab at a health care
plan or not well I mean theoretically
but the problem there is simply that
there are two factions of the Republican
caucus in the house and the
Conservatives and the moderates are not
going to agree on a position on
healthcare over the short term that is a
painful political reality Philip bump
always good to see you thank you for
summarizing yet another chaotic weekend
watching